[Inaudible].
End of March, 2020, during the first wave of the SARS coronavirus to pandemic.
We told you in a video here on visual politic,
the mistakes that Spain had made had caused it to become the worst epicenter of
the pandemic. Well, six months later,
things kind of seem to be back to square one,
and you will soon see that compared to the rest of Europe.
The data from Spain is very, very bad.
The time of making this video,
Spain was accumulating more than 10,000 new positive cases every day.
And total the number of confirmed cases since the beginning of the pandemic is
now well over 800,000 since mid July and after one of the
strictest quarantines and the world Spain has seen its numbers skyrocket again.
And it's not just the positive cases.
The number of deaths have been growing steadily since August as well. Yes,
the numbers are very different from those of March and April,
but with between 100 and 200 deaths every day,
Spain has already amassed around 50,000 deaths to the beginning of the pandemic.
A figure that in relation to its population is the highest rate and the world
behind only the European micro state of sun.
Reno.
No matter what data we look at on a European level,
Spain is by far the country that has worst managed the first wave and is also
the country that is doing the worst job managing.
The second wave. Listen up Spain, once again,
grapples with Europe's worst infection rate the Telegraph.
And actually they win the prize, not only in Europe,
but in the whole developed world,
because the truth is that despite what many Spanish politicians are seeing and
attempts to exculpate themselves,
those dire statistics are not something that is happening all over the world.
Not even anywhere else in Europe, certainly not to the same
Without digging too deeply. There is the case of Italy,
a country that is very socially and culturally, similar to Spain. And which,
as you all know,
during the months of February and March of 2020 was one of the first epicenters
of the pandemic in the world. Well,
to give you a comparison at the time of making this video,
the spread of the virus and excellent was only 46.5 cases per 100,000
inhabitants and 14 days in Spain,
the spread of the virus has increased to 302.4 cases,
6.5 times more than that, Italy take a look at this map.
You see on the screen, as you can see, only the Czech Republic,
where I live the Netherlands and France of figures that are similar to Spanish
levels to say that they're close as a bit of an exaggeration because the spread
rates registered in these countries are still much lower than Spain's.
Something does not add up here. Does it?
And what on earth has been done to find themselves with such figures and October
whose fault is it, and more importantly,
what could have been done to avoid the situation that makes spin. Once again,
trailing the pack of all the other countries of Europe.
Are you ready to investigate? If you are, let's get cracking.
[Inaudible].
From bad to worse.
My visual Paul Amigos, we're talking about spin. You see what I did there,
as you can imagine,
in order to reach the dubious title of the worst Western country,
in terms of the coronavirus by September,
the Spanish must have done something very, very wrong.
Something that in Spain's case began as far back as me and June,
2020 during the so-called deescalation of quarantine measures,
the deescalation was a process of several weeks that serve as a transition
between the total confinement of the population that took place between March
and may and the return to normality through three phases with gradually fewer
restrictions.
We are talking about critical process that if not handled correctly,
carries a risk that this situation will soon get out of control again.
And that is exactly what happened.
The government of Petro Sanchez,
which took control of the process during the quarantine,
by declaring a state of alarm,
which included commandeering some of the powers that regional governments
usually have failed miserably to prepare the country for the return to the new
normal,
such a transition should have included lots and lots and lots of
tests and many managed research to control outbreaks and to keep what is known
as community transmission to an absolute minimum.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Wait a minute because the central government of Spain was by no means the only
one who got it terribly wrong, right?
The autonomous communities,
which in Spain are a bit like state governments have power over public health
and are responsible for managing the health system and their regions.
And they have not been exactly up to the task. At least not many of them have,
for example, and regions such as Madrid, Aragon, and Catalonia,
autonomous governments were unable to set up tracing teams to promptly detect
positive cases and test their environments in order to prevent further sprint
something which has proven to be indispensable in the fight against the Karumba.
Alarm for the insufficient tracers and monitoring of cases,
the experts in this task of surveying the positive cases to assess whether their
contacts or social family or workmates and start their monitoring do not
reach 200 throughout Catalonia Lavonne Gardia,
July 15th, 20, 20 Madrid,
and Catalonia have 15% of the tracers that are needed economic stuff to give you.
Some idea, do you know how many were needed in Madrid and Catalonia?
That is the minimum number to control the virus after confinement. Well,
between 2000 and 3000,
that's a low estimate and calculated for an environment where the pandemic was
under control. Of course. Well, in July, there weren't even 200.
And at the time of making this video and Madrid, for example,
there were only about 800 active tracers,
800 tracers that in practice seem to be stuck simply on the phone.
And it's not the lack of resources is a problem for these governments,
the autonomic governments of Madrid and Catalonia manage annual budgets of more
than 20 and 30 billion years respectively.
But in order to get a more detailed view of what's happened,
let's focus for a moment on the case of Madrid.
[Inaudible].
The community of Madrid, not only the Spanish epicenter,
but also the European and even global epicenter for a good part of the first
wave has once again,
become the region with the highest transmission rate for the Corona virus and
the entire Western world at the beginning of the second wave Madrid was the
recorded incidents of over 700 cases per 100,000 inhabitants in 14
days at the end of September was already the worst source of infection and
Europe for the second time and six months.
And the question, the million dollar question is what has regional president,
Isabel Diaz and her government done to prepare for the second wave after all
they've had plenty of time to do so, right?
What contingency plan did the Madrid government prepare for its citizens as it
watch the cases grew steadily and Catalonia during the month of June,
that they think that Madrid would be immune from a second wave and that they
would not be had again,
despite constant warnings from the medical and scientific community and short,
what were their priorities? Well, here's a taste.
4.5 Million euros in grants in Madrid to support fighting bull
livestock,
ABC Madrid subsidy to the electric bicycle up to 600 euros.
If it is not a sports or high end bike at a confidential, okay.
Now this may seem a little populists on our part, but that is the truth.
These are just two of the many examples we could give the government of the
community of Madrid has proven its lack of clarity about what its priorities.
B.
Sports centers are purchases new facilities for public employees, tax breaks.
You only have to take a look at the community of Madrid's press page to realize
that something something's not quite right,
these are all things that were simply not a priority,
but of course let's not kid ourselves.
It's not surprising that they did all this because the regional president of
Madrid herself, Isabel Diaz, I also told the president of Spain, Pedro Sanchez,
that she believed the pandemic was over. You don't believe me.
Listen for yourself.
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
So is it possible.
But that is the explanation for such a lack of control and such chaos.
Is it possible that Spanish politicians are so disconnected from reality that
they did not realize that the pandemic was not yet over how you can regional
governments spend three months demanding that the central government give them
back their powers and the area of public health,
and then do absolutely nothing.
[Inaudible] DNN
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Rita as it may. The reality is what it is.
And the reality is that since the end of the confinement and in particular,
since early September, when many Madrid residents returned from vacation,
the Madrid subway has been overflowing with people,
the carriages and the platforms we're at full rush hour capacity.
And the safety distances could not be kept because the summer schedule with
reduced frequency was kept well into September.
Without anyone noticing someone was having a siesta at the wheel.
I did that again,
nor did the Madrid government asked the ministry of transport to put more trains
on the metropolitan lanes of rent, freeze,
commuter rail system to avoid congestion. Nothing was done at all.
Protocols and contingency plans were conspicuous by their absence,
a disaster that has caused Madrid to have the highest rate of positive PCR tests
in all of Europe. I'm one of the highest rates in the developed world.
World.
In concrete terms at the end of September 20.7% of the more than 150,000
PCR tests that were being carried out in Madrid each week,
we're coming back positive. We're talking about a contagion rate.
That's twice the national average and four times the limit,
but what's the pandemic is considered to be out of control.
Our limits to the world health organization says it's fine.
To me.
Even if you do about 150,000 tests a week,
more than 20% of the test and Madrid are positive during the month of September,
the virus was running wild so much SU that even with so many
tests,
there were still an adequate in order to control the pandemic and Madrid and
adequately detect infections,
it would be necessary to do about four times more tests,
more than half a million a week.
And not only would this be materially impossible given the available resources,
but also what is actually happening is just opposite.
Even fewer tests are being collected. Check this out.
Madrid will no longer test people in close contact with the positive case,
new guideline in the region. El Espanol.
My Amigos,
the management disaster that Spanish politicians have been leading does not end
there.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] they extend their
[inaudible].
Example. If one is needed of bad management is radar.
COVID an application launched by the Spanish government to report to positive
cases of coronavirus, which some autonomous communities,
such as Madrid and Catalonia had blocked. Why,
how is it possible that the various administrations,
both the government of Spain and the regional governments did not dedicate all
the necessary resources to set up equipment and teams for mass testing and
tracing. They knew, I mean, they had to know that it was something important.
Europe warned about it. The world health organization warned about it.
And the experience of countries that have successfully confronted COVID-19 have
proved it. Test trace isolates.
That was the key formula. However, if we have just seen with the case of Madrid,
the truth is the practically no region took the end of the confinement very
seriously. In fact, as early as July,
just one month after the end of the deescalation outbreaks began to appear all
over the country,
The outbreaks,
but as grip infections of more than three cases with the same origin quickly
multiplied until they got so out of control and a municipality in Garcia and in
the province of leader and Catalonia,
where apparently the cases spread rapidly due to cases, imported from Africa,
by seasonal workers who went to work in the fields. In fact,
one of the biggest mistakes of the autonomous governments was not to guarantee
the health and safety of the seasonal workers who as in previous years were
housed and shared rooms of 10 or even more people without any safety distancing
measures.
These factors forced the confinement of an area in the region of gala SIA and
another in the Providence of leader. However,
while the gala scenes managed to control the outbreak quickly and Catalonia,
the government of queen Torah also failed at least initially to the point that
Lolita outbreaks made the leap to the entire Barcelona metropolitan area.
Of course, during the summer, the virus found it very,
very easy to make the jump to other regions such as Oregon, the Basque country,
Navea and Madrid, where the situation eventually got totally out of control.
There was neither sufficient testing nor widespread screening,
nor efficient contact tracing, nor even sufficiently strict social measures.
And to all of that,
we have to add that the deescalation was already very optimistic. The bars,
the nightlife spots,
and even some of the other popular festivals and public events were opened as
soon as possible.
So that allows us to say that the virus has the ideal breeding ground over the
summer to gather all those pieces and put all of Spain back and check me.
And as we have seen that is precisely what happened.
Another one of the tremendous fiascos during the deescalation on the weeks that
followed was the absolute lack of control and the Spanish ports and airports,
the Spanish government, which is responsible for foreign health,
refuse to test international travelers for coronavirus, not even quick tests,
and also refuse to require a test at origin.
Instead they set up what they called a visual check,
a farce by which public health officials could supposedly detect whether you had
symptoms of coronavirus by looking at you. Yeah, yeah.
With their Superman, like x-ray vision,
they could see within you and see whether or not you were sick.
Just listen to what the health minister himself sent and meant.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
Of course it's hardly surprising that everything got out of control and spin
well. In other places,
the tracing teams worked on border controls were frequent and consistent.
As for example, in Italy, in Spain,
you can see that they were not a sheet of paper, a visual check,
and off you go, but what could possibly be behind such a lack of action,
Amigos Annemarie's tourism accounts for 13% of spins,
GDP and hundreds of thousands of jobs depend on it.
So the government thought it best not to hinder the arrival of travelers.
However, that strategy turned out to be a real disaster.
A few weeks after the start of the tourist season,
the cases began to rise and it was the countries of origin of the tourist
themselves,
the began to discourage and even prevent their citizens from traveling to Spain
or at least to its most effected areas.
We'll establish a quarantine for all travelers coming from Spain,
Lavonne Garcia,
Switzerland joins the other 28 countries that impose a quarantine for travelers
coming from Spain RTV.
In other words,
the Spanish government thought that by not putting measures in place,
they would save the tourist season. But what happened was exactly the opposite.
Yeah.
Seasoned,
lost hundreds of thousands of jobs destroyed or at risk of disappearing and the
Spanish economy recording the largest drop and all of Europe.
And to top it all off the virus, as at large, again, Spanish.
Plunges into recession, GDP falls,
17.8% in the second quarter due to COVID-19
[inaudible].
Yeah. 17.8% to give you an idea.
This is a drop of almost 60% more than the rest of Europe.
And in the third quarter, things are continuing to be just as bad.
The disastrous management of the pandemic is also causing a terrible economic
situation that we'll see Spain recording the worst performances in all of Europe
in 2020.
The 4th of October 20,
20 Spain's toxic politics and health crisis have got Merkel worried.
German officials view the situation in Spain with growing concern.
The resurgence has exposed fractures and systems of government Spain's economy
has collapsed Bloomberg.
Let's take just one moment here at this point.
Many of you are probably asking yourselves how on earth can anyone with
responsibility for governing and managing do such a shocking job?
Who are the people responsible for this disaster? Well, let's take a look.
[Inaudible] the real virus.
You see my visual poem. And he goes,
if there is one thing that differentiates Spain from other countries in Europe
is the SARS cov two Corona virus.
Pandemic is not the only one the country is facing. There is another, the,
I am sorry to say runs rampant among the political class of the country,
that of the extreme incompetence of the leaders and public officials.
Yeah. Okay. Maybe you think I'm being just a little bit too harsh,
but it's just that having made Spain,
the epicenter of the Corona virus and March and letting it happen again in
September without any particular measures having being taken well,
I don't really know you tell me how do I explain.
That.
Case in point it was not until the end of September seven months after the
beginning of the pandemic that the regional government of Madrid had the idea of
installing an operating with great pomp and ceremony.
So many sanitizer jail dispensers on this subway take notes at
the launching of the jail dispensers was attended by the vice president of the
regional government himself Ignacio [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
See my friends when it comes to the crunch, Spanish politicians,
at least many of them don't really seem to know anything.
Take for example, what's happening with the schools.
Spain is the only country in the world that has opened schools and to choose and
universities with such a high rate of spread of the virus couldn't online.
Education plans have been implemented temporarily as South Korea did.
For example,
does it make sense to risk a new uncontrolled spread that could clues companies
and businesses all because they couldn't put spoon or better stagger the return
to classes just two weeks after the return to classes,
many problems had already occurred.
Isabel sailor minister of education confirms that are
2,852 classrooms under quarantine due to coronavirus
antenna, Tracy Noticias, Chivita president of the Navara region,
wrongly orders,
lockdown of healthy students in Nevada and region while keeping Corona virus
infected students in schools, El Espanol,
a single positive in a classroom will not be a reason to quarantine students of
primary, secondary, or baccalaureate education, law opinion. They Mircea.
Really. You couldn't prepare an online alternative for those months
as clear that Spain is once again,
the worst country for the spread of the coronavirus. And no,
it's not something that has anything to do with public spending,
which is by the way, among the highest in the developed world. For example,
Spain has an armed force of 120,000 people,
120,000 people who could have been used to carry out tracing case followups,
testing, monitoring,
or the installation of provisional COVID testing centers to reduce the pressure
on health centers. But Nope, by the fall,
all that has been done is to train 2000 military personnel to be tracers,
to help regions that request it 2000 tracers for the whole of
Spain,
not to mention this thousands of administrative officials who have been sitting
on their thumbs during these months. Yes. Yes.
So think ideally buying while they continue to collect their pay from the
government.
Social security closes its offices to the public. ABC.
Obviously this is not a question of resources above all of agility.
Meanwhile,
in the face of such a serious situation with the worst numbers in the developed
world and a second wave with the numbers of cases and deaths skyrocketing,
the main person responsible for managing the pandemic is engaged in activities
that we can only best describe as
alternative.
But a nano Simone,
a Saturday practicing surfing in Portugal in the middle of the wave of Corona
virus outbreaks,
ABC fender Simone caught diving in the sea of my
Orca with Hazel's Kayla C O P E.
The director of the health alert and emergency coordination center found a
Nando. Simone has been seen accompanied by the Mountaineer. Hey, Zeus.
[inaudible] with whom he is recording a chapter of the TV show Planeta.
I mean, having said that, I don't know, does this seem normal to you?
Because to me it certainly doesn't of course these are not the only awkward
moments where it's be difficult to describe what Simone has been up to during
the pandemic.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Well, I don't know.
It might be funny if it were not for the fact that he's laughing and making
jokes while contagion rates on the death tool just keeps growing it's all a
little bit perverse. Well, the fact is that,
has it been precisely the noses and actions of the authorities,
both of the central government and the regional governments,
which led to 20 Spanish public health experts and epidemiologists to request an
external audit of the public management of the pandemic.
[Inaudible].
A petition that was published in the procedure scientific magazine, the Lancet,
and was signed by important figures and the Spanish scientific community
Megan's sloppiness and competence. I think, you know,
you have a pretty good understanding why Spain is once again,
the worst country in the developed world and both health and economic terms,
it was in this position during the first wave.
And it is all set to do the same thing during the second.
Why on earth haven't Spanish politicians taken a look at the countries that have
faced the pandemic relatively successfully countries like Taiwan, South Korea,
Germany, or the Baltic countries among many others.
All they had to do was copy the best practices.
[Inaudible].
Having said that, what can we expect in the near future? Well,
basically we are faced with two options that spin is simply leading a trend and
that's in the matter of weeks,
the whole of Europe will end up in a similarly bad situation or that Spain will
have a much worse start to the autumn winter wave, none,
its neighbors at the moment,
it seems like the second possibility is the most likely here at visual politic,
our crystal balls are all broken.
And so we cannot predict which of these two things will happen.
But what we can predict is that with the current health data and the economic
damage that is being produced to the Spanish people should reflect on this and
the great financial crisis of 2008,
they were among the worst effected and the 2015 deck races,
they were at the back of the lane and know in 2020 a pandemic is here.
And once again, they are the worst hit.
That is a crisis every four years in which Spain, again, and again,
fears the worst. I don't know about you,
but it looks to me like the model is failing. Doesn't it. And by the way,
this is something that not only spins on citizens,
but also those from all over Europe need to take.
Note of the European union is rescuing these bungling policymakers with hundreds
and hundreds of billions of years,
but they're only making things worse and worse. Does that make sense?
Shouldn't the youth Ortiz take action. Leave your opinion in the comments below.
So we really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast too.
They provided the vocals in this episode, there were not my dulcet tones.
Also this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media. We have a
podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast.
There.